No on Rio and birthday,
who was an existentialist
psychotherapist,
um,
and who was a leader of the
existentialist movement in the 1950s and
also a profound student of
psychoanalysts.
Psychoanalysis talked about something he
characterized as a creative illness,
which was something that manifested
itself in Freud and in you and in other
people like Viktor Frankl for example,
who went through periods of extreme and
Darwin,
extreme periods of chaotic disruption
has their new theories were manifesting
themselves because the new theories tore
them apart as they were being developed
and they paid a tremendous personal
price for that.
But generally they were able to
reorganize themselves within the context
of the new theory and that made their
stance more powerful and more complete
than it was before he described the
characteristic elements of the creative
illnesses follows.
It succeeds a period of intense
preoccupation with an idea and search
for a certain truth.
It's a polymorphous condition that can
take the SAPE of depression,
neurosis,
psychosomatic ailments,
or even psychosis,
whatever the symptoms they are felt as
painful,
if not agonizing by the subject with
alternating periods of alleviation and
worsening it's route.
The onus.
The subject never loses the thread of
his dominating preoccupation.
It's often compatible with normal
professional activity and family life.
Okay.
But even if he keeps to his social
activities,
he's almost entirely absorbed with
himself.
He suffers from feelings of isolation,
even when he has a mentor who guides
them through the ordeal,
like the showman apprentice with his
master.
The termination is often rapid and
marked by a phase of exhilaration.
The subject emerges from his ordeal with
a permanent transformation in his
personality and the conviction that he
has discovered a great truth or a new
spiritual world also happened to Piaget.
Many of the 19th and 20th century
figures recognized universally is great
nature.
Darwin,
Dostoevsky,
Tolstoy,
Freud,
young.
We're also additionally characterized by
lengthy periods of profound
psychological unrest and uncertainty.
Here's our dream that my daughter had
when she was three,
and this is quite a cool dream.
I caught it.
I was able to write it down verbatim
because I was writing at the time.
So she came in to tell me this dream.
So I typed it out because it's not that
easy to catch a kid's dream.
So here was the situation.
So when we brought her brother home from
the hospital,
he is two years younger than her.
We didn't know,
you know,
if there's less than a three year gap
between siblings,
there's a high probability of sibling
rivalry because the old siblings still
needs a lot of attention.
But you know when you have a two year
old you think man that's a baby.
But when you bring a newborn baby home,
that two year olds in adult,
like there's such a radical difference
between a newborn and a two year old.
And so it's hard on the two year old,
right?
Cause they have to grow up right away
and maybe they don't get as much
attention.
So we taught her to,
we taught her to come for a hug when she
needed to by practicing that.
And we also prepared her and told her
that,
you know,
there was going to be some trouble but
she could get some attention from this
new baby.
And that was also her baby.
So she was all prepared for that.
And so she took a lot of care of that
baby and she thought it was her baby and
she liked this baby.
And so she called him baby and then,
you know,
he started to toddle around and,
and uh,
and we told her one day,
well,
he was being toilet trained.
We said,
look,
Mckayla,
he's not really a baby anymore.
And she didn't like that because she
thought,
hmm,
I like that baby.
And now whatever this creature is
apparently is not that baby.
And so what am I supposed to do about
that?
And not as a profound question because
there are lots of parents who don't let
their children progress past the stage
of baby because they don't want to lose
the baby.
And so it's like she was onto something
major.
So,
um,
so this is what she said,
this is your dream.
Julian is the name of her little
brother.
Julian's eyes falled out.
And then he falled into pieces and I
said,
what,
what sort of pieces?
And she said,
Julian pieces.
It's like,
yeah.
And then his bones falled out too.
Then a whole garden and there was water
in it.
And when he came out he was big and my
wife said,
Julian isn't a baby anymore.
And mckayla said,
no,
he's a big boy and above with legs got
him out cause bugs can swim and the hole
was in the park and the park and it
moved into the backyard and he felt he
falled in it,
a tree burned and left the hole.
So that was pretty cool.
That's pretty good.
Grade three,
you know,
three year old kid.
And so the park,
they started,
the place was 42 acres and it was like a
real forest and park.
And I used to take the kids there like
at twilight and you know,
we creep around in there and it was
pretty scary and exciting for them.
So it was sort of an Ick,
scary and exciting place.
It was full of trees and so it was the
unknown outside of our little house.
And so her dream said,
well the unknown had moved into the
backyard in the form of a tree and the
tree burned down.
And a tree is often a symbol of the
psyche.
And it left the hall and the hall was
full of water and then the little baby
went into the water,
dissolved and went into the water.
And then this weird bug guard them out.
So it was some alive thing,
bug.
It's actually,
it was a bug like Jimminy cricket in
Pinocchio,
You know,
cause that's a bug and it's abundant
leads transformation by the way.
So anyways,
the bug got him out and then he was a
big boy and what she was dealing with
was the nature of radical
transformation.
How one thing could turn into something
different and then reconstitute itself
as something else.
And she did that on a symbolic level.
So what time is it?
Three rats.
All right,
well I'll tell you this little story for
one minute.
So I had a five year old nephew and he
was having night terrors,
so we'd wake up at night screaming and
happened a lot.
And uh,
there was some trouble in his family at
that point.
His parents ended up getting divorced,
but anyways,
he'd wake up screaming and he also was
running around during the day with a
little night hat on and like a plastic
sword.
And so he was like,
Joe night,
you know,
and,
and then when he went to bed,
he had the little night out by him and
also the sword.
And so one night when I was there,
he had one of these night terrors.
And so I will,
I was there that morning and I said,
well,
did you dream anything?
And this is what he said,
dwarf like beat creatures who came up to
his knees,
had he was out in the field and they
were like,
so these little things about this big,
they had no arms,
they just had a big head that was beaky
a beak and they were jumping at him with
the beak and like chomping him.
And on the top of their head they,
it was all hairy and greasy and on the
top of their head they had a cross
shaved in it.
So it was like everybody shut up at that
breakfast.
I can tell us like,
oh,
that's what's happening.
It's no,
no wonder you're screaming.
And then so he is fighting away with
these things and they're jumping on him.
But the problem was I said,
he said he,
there was a dragon in the background and
what was happening was the dragon was
breathing out fire all the time and the
fire and the smoke,
we're turning into these boring,
you know,
little dwarf bird things that were
biting him.
And it's like perfect,
right?
It's such a perfect representation.
He can't fight off any one problem cause
it's sort of pointless because there's
something in the background generating
problems like mad.
It's like a hydra cut off one head,
seven more grow.
So I said,
what could you do about that?
Which is a leading question,
right?
Because it implies that he could do
something about that.
So then he said,
I would take my dad and we would go
after the dragon.
I jumped on his head and poke his eyes
out with my sword and then I go down its
belly to where the fire comes out.
And I'd carve out a piece of the firebox
and I'd make a shield out of it.
And I thought,
yes,
that's right.
Yeah.
So,
and one of the things that's very
interesting,
and I know this is hard to believe,
but it's absolutely true.
He did not have any night terrors after
that was extra cool.
And it was the leading question.
It's cause he's like victim,
right?
It's like,
oh my God,
horrible bird headed biting things,
you know,
which is pretty good.
It's like that's what the world's like.
And then there's something in the
background generating these things.
What do you do?
You go to the source of the trouble and
you find something that shields yourself
from it in the encounter.
Brilliant.
All right.